or le moment est il bien choisi pour
cette v progressive des restrictions en
france faut-il voir dans cette stratégie
sanitaire alléger un geste politique à
trois mois de la présidentielle tout de
suite c'est l'heure de notre décryptage
avec nos invités
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler ce soir en
direct alexis poulain éditorialistes rt
france eric revel éditorialiste
politique à distance bonsoir à tous les
deux et sur ce bateau j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir bruno m'égare ban chef du
service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière bonsoir et bruno meyer
vannes et gilles casanova spécialiste de
la communication
bonsoir à vous c'est donc un calendrier
de sortie de crise qu'on a eu ce soir
eric revel pour nous donner un petit peu
de du baume au coeur un peu d'espoir il
était temps
j'aime bien votre optimisme je dirais
que
décidément la politique a ses raisons
que la rationalité humaine ignore j'ai
trouvé le discours du premier ministre
relativement confus je vais vous prendre
plusieurs exemples et puis après je vais
parler un peu sur le fond mais quand le
premier ministre dit à partir de telle
date les masques à l'extérieur ne seront
plus obligatoire la communication du
gouvernement a tellement été confuses
qu'il ya beaucoup de français qui
savaient même pas que c'était
obligatoire c'est là on est un peu dans
un espèce de tourbillon auquel
malheureusement on ne comprend plus
grand chose et pour lequel on est
extrêmement fatiguée mais sur le fond
j'ai vraiment le sentiment que le
premier ministre ait ce gouvernement
essaie surtout de justifier la mise en
application du pass vaccinale le 24
janvier prochain en réalité vous avez
quatre cent soixante quatre cent
cinquante mille cas je crois ce soir
vous avez des statistiques en
réanimation qui continue de baisser mais
le gouvernement veut absolument tient
absolument
être en place se passe vaccinale donc
pour la justifier y continue de nous
tenir en haleine tout en allégeant des
contraintes qui avait été mise en place
un peu rapidement le sentiment que ça
donne pardonnez moi mais c'est une
grande confusion
jusque et y compris quand le premier
ministre
qualifie le virus au micro atx pas si
vous avez entendu il a une formule
absolument génial il a dit quelque chose
du genre il est dangereux mais il est
moins sévère et donc il est sévère mais
il est moins sévère il est donc je vous
le mets pas tout à fait enfin voila
c'est un peu l'aude de de ce discours
alors tant mieux quelles contraintes
soient
levés en deux étapes de février et le 16
février mais vraiment le sentiment que
j'ai c'est que ce gouvernement essaie de
justifier
aussi fort qu'il le peut la mise en
place de ce pass vaccinale la meilleure
des choses si vous considérez que
l'épidémie et les statistiques en
réanimation le montre est en train de se
tasser aussi spectaculairement que ça
s'est passé en afrique du sud ou en
grande bretagne
le mieux aurait été de ne pas mettre en
place ce pass vaccinale mais évidemment
ça aurait été un échec pour le
gouvernement et donc et donc pour le
président de la république qui on sait
va être candidat dans les semaines qui
viennent mais pas tout de suite donné la
parole alexis poulain parce que je sens
qu'il est très tard également je vais
essayer de contrebalancer les grues
nommé dr bâ ne voit là la caution
médicale de cette plaie tôt vous êtes
d'accord avec ce diagnostic d'eric revel
vous beaucoup de politique derrière et
la justification finalement du pass
vaccinale qui va rentrer en vigueur de
20 alors je comprends qu'on puisse faire
des critiques sur la forme évidemment je
j'imagine qu'il ya aussi une certaine
coïncidence entre la possible entrée
en lice pour l'élection présidentielle
du président macron et on va dire le
programme d'allégement des mesures
malgré tout j'allais dire il ya deux
niveaux d' analyse la première c'est le
pass vaccinale en fait le pass vaccinale
ne doit pas s'inscrire dans une
perspective à court terme c'est une
moyen de pousser à la vaccination les
quelques personnes encore non vaccinées
dans un but de protection individuelle
voilà 7 7% de la population adulte 5
millions de français dans un but de
protection à plus long terme car on ne
sait pas dans un avenir proche qu'elle
nous varions pourrait venir et à ce
moment là être responsable et
éventuellement de nouvelles d'une
nouvelle épidémie de covile 19 cents à
paris l'un d'eux ont varié en d'ailleurs
un bea points 2 c'est ça alors ça c'est
un sou variant akron qui a priori on va
dire et peut-être un peut-être un tout
petit peu plus contagieux que mikron lui
même en tout cas il n'a pas plus de
gravité commis crohn il est responsable
peut être à nouveau tout ça est entré le
dating du fait qu'au danemark alors même
que la vague a commencé une quinzaine de
jours avant la france est bien qu'on ait
toujours pas de baisse des
contaminations et peut-être que les
projections initialement un peu
optimiste en france qui voyait déjà à la
mi janvier une baisse des contaminations
eh bien peut-être que le fait qu'on soit
encore sur un plateau élevé et peut-être
même dans certaines régions encore en
augmentation puis c'est attribuable à se
barrer à ceux souvent rien aux microbes
mais en pratique il n'ya pas de
bouleversement de la gravité de
l'épidémie avec ce saut variant alexis
poulain vous entendez bruno megaman je
sais que tous les deux vous n'êtes pas
toujours d'accord
aujourd'hui voilà ce pass vaccinale est
justifiée comme
eric revel mais quand même nécessaire
encore ne l'aura pas le bonhomme et
garonne
je sais pas si enfin ce que j'ai vu ce
soir c'était surtout une agitation
grotesque incompréhensible c'est à dire
que on ne sait plus quelles sont les
mesures les contre-mesures on parle
d'allègement à l'été il est question de
la mise en place de ce pass vaccinale au
plus haut de la vague omicron en disant
que c'est ça qui risque potentiellement
de sauver l'économie française bon
disons le mais clairement j'ai
l'impression que ça patauge en plus haut
lieu à la fois dans la définition de
deux virus à le fait que ces gens-là et
parler de virus dangereux mais moins
dangereux on ne sait pas trop sur les
mesures on voit bien que là on comprend
plus rien et eux mêmes je ne sais pas
s'ils comprennent exactement de quoi il
retourne en attendant ces mesures là et
je pense que la majorité des français
vont être comme moi comme eric à ne rien
comprendre à ce qui s'est passé ce soir
2 février 16 février pour le 14 février
c'est la saint valentin peut-être les
questions de sauver la saint valentin
les restaurateurs je sais pas mais
globalement j'ai rien compris
globalement on comprit apa
voilà bon alors si c'est ça le truc ok
message est clair c'est le même depuis
des mois sa pas beaucoup changé ça
valait pas le coup de se sentir libérant
de sa quarantaine et dire c'est super on
a un truc à vous dire c'est vrai qu'il
est sorti de sa quarantaine en moi je
vois quelques réactions sur internet à
l'issue de ces mesures bien il faut que
tout soit ok pour l'entrée de jupiter
aux élections un vrai spectacle de
guignol et puis puisqu'on a le sens de
l'humour sur rt france la planification
soviétique fait que je ne pourrais pas
boire un verre debout au comptoir avant
le 16 février je vous dis pas le gros
mot derrière
gilles casanova vous le sentez aussi
comme ça un spectacle de guignol pour
finalement donner du baume au coeur à
trois mois de la présidentielle et
donner un cap en tout cas parce que on
le verra après avec mono mega man c'est
vrai qu'on va tenter d'expliquer ce
chiffre du 2 février mais enfin votre
sentiment en ce qu pas mon sentiment
personnel que je vais essayer de vous
exposer mais je vais essayer de vous
donner quelques éléments du communicant
88% des français interrogés à la fin de
la semaine dernière déclaré qu'ils
étaient lassés des mesures
gouvernementales changeantes
ça fait beaucoup 88 exact on en a parlé
hier c'est presque autant que les
vaccinés ont d'autre part j'ai écouté le
premier ministre avec attention et j'ai
lu les décodeurs de libération et ceux
du monde avec la même attention le
premier ministre indique que dans son
monde à lui le vaccin protège totalement
de micron les décodeurs de libération
indique à partir d'une série de sources
officielles qu'il protège à 15% ça fait
que 85 % d'écart finalement voyez ce
n'est pas tant que ça ensuite il indique
que si on a fait la troisième dose on
est dans les semaines qui suivent on
monte jusqu'à 49% mais ça ne dure pas
très longtemps alors pour ça qu'on parle
de la quatrième dose donc on est là
devant un dispositif où on nous parle
d'affaires de santé alors qu'on nous
fait de la politique vous rendez vous
compte de cette liberté recouvrée le 16
février vous pourrez boire un thé debout
au bar est allé danser casanova oui
c'est pas encore fait on va voir ensuite
si c'est pas repoussé mais le votre thé
debout au bar vous pourrez vous allez
voir c'est un air de liberté attention
si vous avez fait la troisième dose si
vous n'êtes pas dans les méchants des
méchants c'est à dire que on a un
système où on organise de façon
extrêmement autoritaire quelque chose
qui n'a rien à voir avec la maladie le
virus ou le vaccin et ensuite on chante
qu'on organise la liberté alors moi j'ai
lu
l'ong entretien de stéphane rozès sur ce
sujet qui explique que c'est le moyen
d'empêcher la présidentielle de parler
des sujets de la présidentielle et de ne
parler que du bonheur d'avoir emmanuel
macron à la tête du pays je crois que
c'est ça alors on va voir ce calendrier
un parce qu'il n'ya pas que le thé
debout donc je le disais réouverture des
discothèques reprise des concerts après
avoir opté en regardant concerts et des
consommations donc ça vous le disiez
debout dans les bars le 16 février le 16
février on le sait c'est quand même la
veille des vacances pour une zone
importante l'île de france qui va pour
certains en tout cas quelques chanceux
vont se précipiter dans les stations ce
qui peut-être dans les discothèques veut
nommer germann le médecin que vous êtes
ne trouve pas cela un petit peu anticipé
ces allègements pourquoi cette date sans
compter évidemment le 2 février a
terminé les jauges dans les stades le
masque à l'extérieur c'est vrai qu'on
avait du match personnellement je
croyais que ç'avait été enlevés cette
semaine dans l'extérieur quand je le
portais j'ai enfreint la loi sans voile
a nnoncé ces dates là vous vous les
expliquer en tant que de ça alors je dis
vivement pourquoi le gouvernement
aujourd'hui
prend des décision d'alléger les mesures
de restriction parce que malgré tout il
y à de bonnes nouvelles sur le front du
coc vide et c'est ça qu'il faut bien
mettre en avant effectivement la vague
delta est en train de se réduire et
c'est elle qui est responsable des
admissions de patients pour des formes
graves de pneumonie en réanimation de
fait nous avons moins d'entrants tous
les jours même si il y à il y en a
toujours deuxième point au micron qui
est un niveau de contamination
extrêmement élevés risquent quasiment
450 me
servant un demi million de contamination
quotidiennes sont observés et donc
heureusement pour nous il est finalement
responsable que très rarement de formes
graves et donc on va dire c'est plutôt
rassurant on en a désormais la certitude
même si effectivement encore les
admissions à l'hôpital continue à
augmenter aujourd'hui 27000 admission en
hospitalisation conventionnelle avec
tous les jours quand même
il faut insister 2500 personnes qui
rentrent pour une pneumonie
certes peut-être pas très grave mais lié
à ce variant alors on va dire en
regardant ce qui se passe dans les pays
autour de nous c'est à dire
essentiellement au royaume uni mais
aussi en espagne en grèce on commence à
voir régresser l'épidémie avec une
vitesse relativement rapide c'est à dire
une diminution par deux du nombre de
contaminations chaque semaine donc de
fait on peut émettre un certain
optimisme alors les mesures de sortie de
restrictions n'ont pas été prises demain
on prend justement pourquoi on prend le
début février parce qu'il ya encore une
dizaine de jours pour être sûr que l'on
va être sur la pente descendante des
contaminations car aujourd'hui on est
encore si on regarde les chiffres
nationaux on est encore un tout petit
peu en augmentation avec 2% de
progression donc il faut attendre dix
jours dans dix jours on sera sur la
pente descendante
et puis comme vous l'avez dit les
mesures sont progressives ou commence
par les jauges et puis ensuite on
s'oriente vers l'ouverture des
discothèques alors tout ça quand même je
tiens à le dire
c'est vrai que ça a l'air un peu
dirigiste je ne critique pas mais quand
même il y a aussi beaucoup de
responsabilisation de la population car
il faut savoir qu'au mois de février on
aura toujours des contaminations
extrêmement élevé c'est même si ça va
baisser de moitié chaque semaine on sera
encore des chiffres jamais atteints en
termes de contamination fin février donc
le virus va circuler encore massivement
mais il est vrai que nous sont sur une
pente descendante et que la population
évidemment a aussi besoin de
perspectives
et puis surtout que désormais il faut
vivre avec ce virus est oui et alors aux
roues avant pour donner la parole et les
crevettes écoutez quand même ce que
disait le conseil scientifique ce matin
la cinquième vague omicron n'est pas
terminée et son retentissement sur le
système de soins va rester élevé mais en
partie gérable et ce jusqu'à mi mars et
ce jusqu'à mi mars l'allègement c'est
pour le 2 février puis le 16 février
là encore une forme de logique selon
vous le président n'écoute plus le
conseil scientifique
écoutez je sais pas si il les goûts tous
ils écoutent pas vain quand j'écoute le
professeur megaman je suis je suis
résolument admiratif de ce qu'il dit
parce que la plupart des sachions nous
expliquent qu'ils ne savent pas donc je
fais beaucoup d'intérêt ce que dit le
professeur mais en réalité depuis le
début
évidemment on peut pas reprocher au
gouvernement d'avoir tâtonner mais on
peut reprocher quand même à ce
gouvernement si on a un peu de mémoire
d'avoir raconté des choses
d'une semaine sur l'autre qui se sont
avérées ou bien totalement fausses ou
bien mensongère le pass vaccinale je
vous rappelle quand même que l'on nous a
expliqué qu'il aurait jamais de
vaccination obligatoire on le passe
vaccinale si vous n'avez pas le 24
janvier vous pourrez pas fallon chez
vous donc en fait elle est obligatoire
moi je pense réellement
évidemment je ne suis pas un
scientifique mais je pense réellement
que
l'élection présidentielle qui est
maintenant en point de mire
tonnes à toutes ces décisions un lustre
différent évidemment parce que en
réalité emmanuel macron va vouloir
apparaître un peu comme le sauveur bon
espérons que cette vague va s'affaisser
il veut il veut pas parler de choses qui
sont plus contraignantes pour lui payer
on peut lever les contraintes sanitaires
ne peut pas levée des contraintes d'un
bilan or son bilan il n'est pas
fantastique je pense qu'il a loupé par
exemple hier à strasbourg il a été pris
comme une sorte de cible par différents
leaders de l'opposition française au
parlement de strasbourg peu importe la
question de savoir si c'était lieu ou
pas le lieu il est sorti de son discours
il a lui-même été confus donc en fait je
pense que plus longtemps on va être sous
passe vaccinale plus longtemps on sature
à médiatiquement avec ce sujet les
radios les télévisions les journaux et
ça permettra évidemment à une groupe
décaler son entrée en campagne et
surtout
d'en dire plus sur son projet et sur son
bilan quand même il faut pas être dupe
faut pas être naïf j'ai commencé par une
petite phrase que j'aime bien que j'aie
vouloir donner c'est que la politique a
ses raisons que la rationalité humaine
quotidienne ignore mais c'est exactement
ça c'est à dire vous avez des raisons
politiques et en face vous avez une
rationalité quand on vous parlait du
gourou possible variant et que le
professeur mais garde à vous expliquer
qu'il était sans doute plus contagieux
mais pardonnez moi le delta il était
déjà très contagieux le mikron il était
déjà très très contagieux et on vous le
dit qu'il ya un virus qui va être plus
contagieux très contagieux mais quand
est ce que vous voulez que les gens
comprennent quelque chose et adhère pour
le reste chers amis vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure vous avez oublié votre maître
votre masse parce que c'est ce que je
disais la plupart des français savent
même pas que ça devait être un masque
donc ils sont autant la preuve qu'il
faut plus omettre l ex poulain pour
rebondir sur ce que dit eric revel c'est
vrai que la cote de popularité dans
certains sondages d'emmanuel m ont
commencé un petit peu infléchir ces
derniers jours il a ce sondage aussi
capable point fr en me semble-t-il qui
indique que 88 % des français vraiment
un peu plus de ces mesures quoi qu'il en
coûte il était temps de toute manière
d'agir du côté de l'exécutif quoi qu'il
en coûte peut-être même au niveau de
sanitaires finalement
rien de sanitaire enfin depuis le début
c'est une mise en scène de communicants
assez médiocre rappelez-vous en fall la
mise en scène devant un parking de
supermarché devant un hôpital de
campagne pour expliquer que nous étions
en guerre il ya eu des sorties de route
terrible avant le avant le confinement
emmanuel et brigitte macron qui disait à
tous les français d'aller vite au
théâtre c'était super qu'il fallait
absolument garder l'économie ouverte les
masques enfin les nombreux mensonges qui
a pu avoir par le passé donc tout n'est
que communication et boursouflures
autoritaire depuis le début et c'est un
assez inquiétant de se dire qu'on est 70
millions de français adultes à être
traités comme des enfants par un seul
homme qui décide de tout un conseil de
défense entouré d'un aéropage de gens
choisis qui lui disent qu'il est le
soleil de lisez c'est flippant on est en
république française alors on a un
parlement qui s'exécute qui a discuté
pendant quinze jours d'impasse vaccinale
avec gérard larcher président du sénat
qui au final dit oui on va peut-être
faire des commissions d enquête pour
voir si ce pass sert à quelque chose
avec philippe bas patron des
républicains qui dit je vote pour cette
loi même si je sais pas à quoi elle sert
réellement ben on se demande à quoi
servent réellement nos parlementaires
aussi parce que ce débat là il est
éthique il est des ontologies qu'il est
au delà même du sanitaire c'est une
question profonde sur l'état de droit
est adroit qui étaient mentionnés par
les mâcon dans son discours d'hier au
parlement européen alors l'état de droit
il est foulée aux pieds par ce président
depuis deux ans avec un état d'urgence
sanitaire qui lui permet de gouverner
par décrets qui lui permet de gouverner
par ce conseil de défense sous le sceau
du secret défense en dehors de tout
cadre démocratique en réalité donc on
est là à vivre haha délire absolu
démocratique depuis deux ans que je
dénonce et que on est plusieurs à
dénoncer à cette antenne et ça ne fait
que continuer c'est à dire ce soir on
met en scène jean castex et olivier
veyrat qui ont un duo comique maintenant
depuis quelques mois qu'on commence à
connaître et qui refont le duo comique
avec des mesures abracadabrantesque bah
finalement vous pourrez boire debout
super merci beaucoup monsieur castex
mais j'avais pas besoin de vous pour le
faire en réalité et il se passe
vaccinale qui pose la question à 90% de
la population adulte vacciner à quoi
sert ce pass vaccinale si ce n'est à
faire entrer des idées comme quoi il y
aura des bons et des mauvais citoyen
comme quoi il y aurait peut-être un
potentiellement à qui se profile à un
contrat de citoyenneté impasse de
citoyenneté à la chinoise en fonction de
si vous obéissez ou non au roi ou un
président ou un parti j'en dirais que ça
quand même préciser en cas que se passe
ça va vous faire plaisir alexis pourrait
être suspendue si la pression épidémique
est sûre tous quitté hier venait à se
réduire fortement et durablement on va
regarder cette troupe justement de
pression hospitalière et on va se
tourner vers bonhomme égard ban et si
nos hôpitaux n'était plus obligé de
déprogrammer des soins si la pression
sanitaire redescendre est au plus bas on
voit cette coupe qui est assez
instructif bruno megaman justement cette
déprogrammation ça c'est un vrai sujet
vous vous le constatez dans votre
hôpital il ya cette déprogrammation elle
est peut-être aussi parce qu'on n'a rien
fait pour le système de santé français
n'est ce pas et pas forcément qu'à cause
du virus alors je vais vous répondre
pour commencer sur la déprogrammation
puis après juillet a apporté quelques
précisions sur le pass alors donc
effectivement la déprogrammation oui on
la constate elle a été décidée massive
il y à une trois semaines parce
qu'effectivement les hôpitaux avaient
peur d'avoir une arrivée importante de
patients infectés par omicron finalement
la situation sanitaire est moins grave
que prévu même s'il y a un nombre
important de patients en hospitalisation
au conventionnel
l'ensemble des hôpitaux a décidé de
réduire le pourcentage de
déprogrammation par exemple à
lariboisière nous étions passés de 70 %
de déprogrammation aujourd'hui environ
15% de thé programmation donc la
situation va mieux d'ailleurs c'est dans
cette perspective déjà que les décisions
de levée des restrictions est prise
alors je dirais le pass d'abord il faut
comprendre le parce qu'ils soient
sanitaires ou vaccinale ça n'est qu'un
outil ce qui est important c'est la
vaccination est bien une étude faite à
montpellier a montré que depuis un an la
vaccination à éviter 48 mille décès en
france alors effectivement pour inciter
les gens à se faire vacciner eh bien il
a fallu d'abord le pass and i ter 15
millions de personnes qui sont vaccinées
à cause du passé ni terre et une étude
récente a montré que le pass sanitaire a
permis de d'éviter 4000 décès c'est à
dire dans les quarante huit mille 4000
était uniquement lié au fait qu'un pass
sanitaire avait été instauré alors
maintenant que fait le pass vaccinale en
plus évidemment il essaye de mettre une
pression supplémentaire
alors le président voilà monsieur
monsieur castex l'a rappelé un million
de personnes ont fait leur primo
vaccination al'annonce de ce pass
vaccinale donc on voit bien qu'il ya un
certain effet mais je suis d'accord cet
effet va se réduire en fonction du temps
cas de plus en plus on va avoir une
population non vaccinée qui soit
totalement convaincu du danger du vaccin
et qui même avec tremblement de terre ne
se fera pas vacciner et puis une autre
population qui elle justement est le
problème ce sont des gens qui soient
hésite soissons non loin du système de
santé est en fait là les verts et
peut-être le défaut de la stratégie
sanitaire du gouvernement
il faut renforcer absolument c'est aller
vers des personnes qui sont âgées
isolées qui n'ont pas de médecin
traitant qui ne vont pas à la pharmacie
que l'on pourraient vacciner car
malheureusement lorsqu'ils sont
contaminés et c'est ce qu'on voit eh
bien ils décident ils prennent un risque
de décès et je rappelle tous les jours
en france il y à 250 morts liées à la
copie gilles casanova je vois on appelle
à la responsabilisation des français il
faudrait dans ce cas
essayer de leur donner des éléments
réels et non des éléments imaginaire en
termes d'information par exemple
monsieur castex nous a dit que c'était
les non vaccinés qui était un
raz-de-marée à l'hôpital il se trouve
que les fat shaker de libération vérifie
la chose et sont arrivés à la conclusion
que c'était 44% de vacciner et donc une
majorité non vaccinés certes mais ce
n'est pas un raz-de-marée ensuite que
les hôpitaux sont remplis de gens qui
sont là pour le coc vide alors là aussi
comme santé publique france maintenant
donne des détails le monde lui même
aujourd'hui après libération hier
indique que selon les classes d'âge
c'est entre 20 et 40% des personnes qui
sont à l'hôpital et qui sont indiqués
comme qu'ovide 19 qui sont à l'hôpital
pour d'autres raisons et qui ont été
testées et qui ont été trouvés positive
aux convives 19 variant au micron mais
qui n'ont pas forcément de symptômes de
cela qu'ils sont là parce qu'ils ont une
jambe cassée qui sont là parce qu'ils
ont une autre maladie et donc santé
publique france et maintenant conduit à
donner ce détail et je voudrais indiquer
notre ami que si on avait annoncé une
décharge électrique lieu de
l'interdiction d'aller au café la
vaccination aurait été plus rapide car
c'est le principe du nudge cher à ceux
qui ont aidé les chinois a créé le
crédit social et qui ont aidé les
français a créé le pass sanitaires et le
transformer en passe pas au final c'est
à dire les américains de mckinsey qui
coûte très cher et qui ont cette idée du
nudge alors il ya la décharge électrique
c'est un homme un peu plus élevé il y
avait la tradition française c'était
l'obligation vaccinale il suffisait de
la voter mais ça le gouvernement n'a
jamais réussi à proposer l'obligation
vaccinale un certain nombre de députés
de l'opposition ou proposer comme
proposition de loi fait obligation
vaccinale que le gouvernement a refusé
le mettre à l'ordre du jour donc est ce
que ce n'est pas avant tout la petite
décharge électrique que le gouvernement
veut habitués les français à prendre bon
en tout cas on va aborder la dernière
partie de ce décryptage avec la partie
école qui a été l'objet de grandes
critiques cela était encore aujourd'hui
avec la mobilisation des enseignants
écouter jean castex sur ce point avec le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et le
ministre de la santé j'ai reçu les
représentants des personnels de
l'éducation nationale et nous avons
apporté les correctifs nécessaires mais
rien n'aurait été pire que de fermer des
établissements scolaires voire de
retarder la rentrée car la réouverture
vu la flambée du nombre de cas auraient
été très difficile avant-hier mardi
17 mille trente sept classes étaient
fermés c'est beaucoup mais cela
représente
3,2 pour cent des classes en france
3,2 pour cent si comme certains nous le
suggère nous avions fermé 100% des
classes je vous laisse déduire vous-même
toutes les conséquences je suis
convaincu que notre choix a été le bon
eric revel il ce qu'on va lui même jean
castex que le choix était le bon
je vais vous dire je vais déduire une
conséquence pour le premier ministre qui
a pas osé le dire mais je lui en déduire
une 600 % des classes avaient été fermés
l'économie française était par terre
pour une raison très simple c'est que
les parents étaient obligés de rester à
la maison pour garder leurs enfants or à
trois mois de la présidentielle une
économie française qui rebascule ray
dans la dépression économique
là on parlera même pas de bilan si vous
voulez ce serait juste à un cataclysme
pour le président-candidat donc l'une
des conséquences que l'on pourrait tirer
à la place de jean castex qu'il avait
peut-être mais qui paie pas la formule
et c'est que si vous fermez 100% des
classes vous obligé de demander aux
parents de rester et donc l'appareil
productif globalement ne tourne plus en
france et là l'économie française
rebascule dans la récession c'est une
des conséquences on peut tirer ces
fermetures de classes parfois je retiens
ce texte qui donne des pistes nos sols
je fais pas ci fais exprès puis l'est
ses hôtes réfléchir et quand on
réfléchit un peu rosies mes raisons
c'est pas bon pour mâcon ça que
l'économie française ont basculé dans la
récession alexis bollart on voit sourire
soyez rapide s'il vous plaît mais enfin
quand même temps on était peut-être en
tant que parent également ravis de voir
les écoles restées ouvertes ne serait ce
que pour l'éducation de nos enfants
également n'est ce pas mais bien sûr
même si les professeurs eux n'ont pas eu
cette même expérience amoureuse c'était
plutôt de l'ordre de la garderie avec la
difficulté de tenir les masques huit
heures par jour avec ces tests multiples
qui ont été un calvaire pour les enfants
comme pour les parents a bien sûr non
mais c'est dire je pense que c'est la
bascule aussi c'est qu'à un moment c'est
juste intenable au niveau personnel de
faire un tel protocole alors là encore
jean castex à la réponse il faut
vacciner les enfants dès 5 ans donc il
va falloir davantage de lieux de
vaccination davantage de deux praticiens
qui vont pouvoir faire la vaccination
des enfants donc on voit bien que le
plan reste le tout vaccinal à 200 % même
si l' oms se pose la question d'une
vaccination de masse de 2 c'est est-ce
que c'était un choix qui est réellement
utile aujourd'hui ce qu'il ne faut pas
se concentrer sur des populations à
risque et puis la question des boosters
bien sûr aussi qu'est posée mais
le gouvernement l'a ne fait plus du
sanitaire il a choisi la vaccination de
masse avec l'aide de pfizer et puis le
reste c'est on doit tenir jusqu'à avril
il faut qu emmanuel macron puisse se
présenter sur les bases de j'ai gagné
contre le coc vide avec mes petits
points je suis quand même le meilleur
mais rien ne dit que un nouveau variant
n'arrivera pas dès le mois de juin dès
le mois de juillet ou à la rentrée de
septembre en tout cas clairement les
choix qui sont guidés aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement sont des choix politiques
qui n'ont rien de sanitaires et qui ont
en ligne de mire l'élection
présidentielle et la date de déclaration
nature est belle macro qui se fait
toujours attendre d'ailleurs merci
beaucoup alexis poulain eric revel j'ai
dit casanova et bruno mégarde à voir
avec nous pour ce décryptage et on l'a